allison how are we doing this morning so
i'm really
battling myself right now with
um a regretful decision a big decision
that my husband and i have made
oh um he retired from the military a
year ago
and we had planned on always
settling back home near my family i'm
the only child
i'm very close with my mom she's my best
friend
and he had a job lined up and everything
well he ended up getting a better job
offer
in a state we used to live in we were
stationed there before
and we jumped the gun and decided
financially we're gonna do it um
and we moved to this other state that
job fell through
i did not get it and now he's doing the
job now he's a police officer
he's doing the job now that he had lined
up
back home near my family um
in virginia and i just feel like the
past year i just
i don't know what's wrong with me like i
just can't move beyond this
and it's been it's been hard
so did does he not want to move anymore
um this new police department he works
for yeah he does and i'm very grateful
for this department you know with
everything going on we are very lucky to
be where we are right now
um the community shows nothing but love
towards them
he is flourishing and i love watching
that for him it's been his dream job
um but we do have three children
and i am the only one not his fault but
i'm the one that has to take our kids to
their games
in their school events and you know i
don't have support with my family it's
just mom
still after you know a whole military
career and
i struggle with it every every time so
if you
not in a moment of frustration not in a
moment of rage or anger or
exhaustion have you sat down and talked
to him about it
i have and he would move in a heartbeat
okay um
so why why don't you move
um i think it's my kids i always said i
wanted to settle be settled
when my oldest started middle school
okay he started middle school the year
we moved here so he's now in seventh
grade we've got a fifth grader and we've
got a second grader
and i just want stability for them i am
tired of moving
i know but listen you're not stable
a mom who lives a life of
regret and who lives a life of
constant frustration i'm telling you
those kids are absorbing that
and you've heard me say this and i'm
going to say it a thousand more times
before
dave ramsey fires me someday you
those kids feel that on you and they
backfill that
gap between you and them with it must be
their fault
and they will spend every waking moment
trying to make sure that the
relationship with mommy's okay
and they're not going to do it on
purpose and you're not doing it on
purpose
but if you've got a situation where your
husband is ready to pack up and go
you were you were blessed in this season
you had man it's been a gnarly year for
police officers
good and bad and he had a supportive
group that trained him and taught him
and rallied around him in a community
that supported him
what a gift and you've got three healthy
kids
be bopping along you're exhausted from
moving
i've got all that but they need a
settled mom
they need a settled mom and they need a
mom that feels good
here's the thing you need to make sure
that your picture of what virginia's
going to look like is real and it's not
a fantasy
well that's the problem that when you
get there right that
everyone's just going to run it's going
to be like the old days and you're
they're going to dote on you and be
there to pick up your kids and go to the
games with you
it may not happen like that
and it may be that you're avoiding
creating friendships wherever you are
and it's hard for a military spouse
right that's i mean you've you've lived
a nomad's life that's really tough
but at some point when you decide i'm
going to be settled you're going to have
to plug in
and make new friends make new community
be vulnerable with people that you don't
know and
continue to lean into that
and if your family does that for you
virginia awesome i i
i just talk to so many people who it's
just gonna be that way once they can
just get wherever
they are gonna go and the worst part
about moving is that you're gonna go
with you
right and if you're a person who's not
settled who hasn't been settled who's
got regret in her heart because her
husband's moved her around the u.s
government's moved her around
that's not just gonna go away when you
land in virginia
no and i mean my husband says he'll move
but he does not like virginia
right so i think that's part of my
health back too um
great great but he's really going to
love a wife who doesn't feel like a
martyr
and he's really going to love a
connected family
and at some point somebody's got to give
and if you are if you are
living less than if you are
living a life of regret
of just i tell you what man
i can want to live in a lot of places
but the place i want to live is where my
wife feels like her best self
right now your best self in many ways is
a choice
you've got to decide to be fully you
wherever you are
admittedly that could be easier with
family and connection and all those
things
right so if you've got a guy that's
willing to go
and you want to make one more last move
make one more last move
you deserve that he deserves that your
kids deserve that
but it's not going to solve everything
and when you get there you're going to
have to decide
i am plugging in and i'm growing roots
and i'm going to have to do the work
to not be a bitter wife
not be a frustrated person what's
past is past we did move our kids around
a lot i've moved around a lot i lost
10 years or however many years of
relationships of connections of whatever
whatever whatever partridge in a pear
tree
we're moving forward
so i'm gonna invite people to come to
games with us i'm gonna invite
people to have meals over at our house
especially my husband's at work in the
late shift
i'm gonna invite family members over i'm
going to go see a counselor so i can
learn new skills on how to
to plant deep roots i'm going to be
plugged in
because it may be allison that a move is
going to really be great for you
it was for my family it was really
important it was good
and when we got here we still had to
realize that we came with us and we said
a ton of work to do my wife and i
on reconnecting and re-learning how to
be married again
and really that's happened every time we
moved to new cities
good for your husband for loving where
he's at but being willing to pack up and
move good for him
i say y'all start looking at real estate
in virginia and he needs to get his
application in asap and you'll need to
go for it
when you decide to move when you finally
move and land there
probably six months right i want you to
call me back and let me know how you're
doing
call me and let me know how your
family's doing
call me and let me know how your
marriage is doing but i want you to go
let yourself off the hook don't be the
martyr just go
awesome good for you i'm excited for you